Traductor: Florencia Bracamonte
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Loki, el embaucador, se retorcía
bajo el implacable yugo de Thor.
La noche anterior, mientras
los demás dioses dormían,
se escabulló en la habitación
de la esposa de Thor, Sif,
y le cortó su hermosa cabellera.
Le pareció una broma
graciosa en el momento,
pero por ella Thor estaba dispuesto
a romperle todos los huesos.
Loki debía pensar cómo
solucionar lo que había hecho.
Sin embargo, ¿quién podría reemplazar
el inigualable cabello de Sif,
dorado como un campo de trigo en verano?
¡Los enanos!
Estos legendarios herreros
podían fabricar lo que fuera.
Entonces, Loki se dirigió aprisa a
su reino en lo profundo de las montañas.
Incluso antes de llegar,
el astuto de Loki tramaba
cómo conseguiría que los enanos
hicieran lo que él quería.
Decidió que su mejor alternativa
era enfrentar a dos familias.
Primero visitó a
los habilidosos hijos de Ivaldi.
Les dijo que sus rivales,
unos hermanos llamados Brokk y Eitri,
se jactaban de ser
los mejores herreros del mundo
y estaban dispuestos a
demostrarlo en una competencia.
La regla era que cada familia debía
fabricar tres regalos para los dioses.
A los Ivaldi les correspondía
crear una cabellera dorada.
Luego, Loki visitó a Brokk y a Eitri
y les comentó lo mismo,
con la diferencia de que ahora, explicaba,
los hijos de Ivaldi eran los retadores.
Pero Brokk y Eitri
no eran fáciles de engañar,
y accederían a participar únicamente
si Loki ponía en juego su cabeza.
Literalmente, si Brook y Eitri ganaban,
recibirían la cabeza de Loki como premio.
A Loki no le quedó
más alternativa que acceder.
Y, para salvarse,
debía asegurarse de que los hijos
de Ivaldi resultaran victoriosos.
Ambos grupos comenzaron a trabajar.
Eitri ordenó a Brokk atender el fuelle
y no detenerse por ningún motivo,
o los tesoros se arruinarían.
En ese momento, una extraña
mosca negra entró en la habitación.
Mientras se colocaba un trozo
de piel de cerdo en la fragua,
la mosca picó a Brokk en la mano,
pero el enano ni siquiera parpadeó.
Luego, mientras Eitri
trabajaba con un bloque de oro,
la mosca mordió a Brokk en el cuello.
El enano no se detuvo.
Por último, Eitri colocó
un trozo de hierro en la caldera.
Esta vez la mosca se posó
justo en el párpado de Brokk
y lo mordió con todas sus fuerzas.
Por un breve instante, las manos
de Brokk soltaron el fuelle.
Su último tesoro no había permanecido
en el fuego el tiempo requerido.
Loki reapareció en su forma habitual,
contento por el fracaso de los enanos,
y los acompañó a presentar
sus regalos a los dioses.
Loki presentó primero
los tesoros de los hijos de Ivaldi.
La cabellera dorada se unió a la cabeza
de Sif y continuó creciendo,
volviéndola más radiante que antes.
Luego, para Odín, el rey de los dioses,
una magnífica lanza
que podía atravesarlo todo.
Y finalmente para Frey,
el dios de la cosecha,
un pequeño paño que, al desdoblarse,
se convertía en un formidable barco.
Luego, Brokk presentó los tesoros
que su hermano y él habían fabricado.
Para Frey, un jabalí dorado
capaz de tirar de su carruaje
y surcar los cielos más rápido
que cualquier caballo.
Para Odín, una argolla que producía
ocho más, idénticas, cada nueve noches.
Y para Thor, un martillo llamado Mjolnir.
Su empuñadura era muy corta,
y Loki se burló del evidente defecto.
Pero entonces Brokk reveló
cuáles eran sus habilidades:
Mjolnir nunca se rompería,
nunca erraría un golpe,
y siempre regresaría a la mano
de Thor cuando él lo lanzara.
A pesar de la corta empuñadura,
todos los dioses concordaron
en que era el mejor de los regalos.
Al recordar lo que estaba en juego,
Loki intentó escapar, pero Thor lo detuvo.
Antes de que los enanos
reclamaran su premio,
el astuto Loki señaló que habían ganado
su cabeza, pero no su cuello.
Por ende, no podían cortarlo.
A regañadientes, todos admitieron que Loki
tenía razón, pero Brokk reiría al último.
Con el punzón de su hermano, perforó
los labios de Loki y le cosió la boca,
para que así el dios tramposo
ya no pudiera engañar a nadie más.
Los dioses reconocieron
lo irónico de la situación,
pues fue gracias al engaño de Loki
que obtuvieron sus valiosos tesoros,
incluso el martillo de Thor, por el que
el dios es reconocido hasta la fecha.